[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un autour de la table je crois
les cherry pour le moment moi j'ai pris
une grande décision
quand j'étais revenue de vacances
j'avais bien maigri et bien figurez vous
que j'ai re grossi donc tous les jours a
pas je vais me poser ici dans cette
émission non si si complètement avec la
semaine d'autres mis à l'arrêt dans
complètement comme ça voilà donc et
chaque jour j'ai deux semaines on va
dire chez deux semaines pour perdre 5
kilos alors fait non 4 kg et au soleil
j'ai deux semaines noté mme lagarde
j'ai deux semaines pour perdre son g
j'ai tout semaine pour perdre 4 kg
d'accord le shérif ousmane pilier vous
[Rires]
regardez donc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mecs qui m'ont mis une
balance en direct mais qui suffit que ça
je comprends rien de regarder 92 mais
non armés qui les conduit aussi à des
mecs mais je comprends rien mais
regardez je fais 13000 qu'ils allaient
ils vont aller me chercher une autre
ballon je vais me poser dans un instant
parce qu'ils avaient oublié la balance
cette bande dormard donc je sais pas où
j'en étais à merci